hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to talk about twitching
underneath the left eyelid now sometimes
it's on the right
occasionally it's on the arm sometimes
it's on your nose sometimes on your lip
so what is behind this whole twitching
thing it's called tetany really it's a
problem with a certain mineral and
there's a nerve that comes out through
here up underneath the eyelid right
there it's called the facial nerve and
then this deficiency shows up at the end
of that nerve and it's really
hypocalcemia which is basically low
calcium
it's a calcium deficiency but my whole
question is why why are you deficient in
calcium this doesn't make sense you know
if you're eating healthy which I'm sure
you are well let's let's look at the
common causes of low calcium number one
it's high phosphorus that's the opposite
mineral so phosphorus is usually in a
lot of meats and things like that and it
also you'd have to eat a lot of eating
probably like be on the Atkins for a
long time to actually have that but more
likely it's more sodas it's like so does
like cokes and things like that or Pepsi
with all that phosphoric acid that would
do this right here it also number two it
could be a low parathyroid now that's
rare there's a gland on your neck right
around your thyroid is called the
parathyroid if there's a low parathyroid
that can create this problem rare but it
can happen
low back museum could create this
problem but the most common cause is
alkalosis that means your body is too
alkaline now let me explain this because
when I talk of a page there's a whole
bunch of confusion it's like what pH are
you talking about I'm talking about the
blood pH normally when your blood is too
alkaline and let me just explain
normally a pH should be alkaline in a
very narrow range c7 is neutral when you
go higher it's too alkaline when you go
lower than 7 its acid so the blood
operates on 7.35 to 7.45 that's the
narrow band
of range that it must be in so your body
will do everything to keep that range
really really tight so anything higher
and 7.45 its higher that's to Auckland
this is considered alkalosis so what
happens when your pH is too alkaline
the calcium no longer becomes free it
binds with the protein in your blood
called albumin so basically it locks up
the calcium okay so you need an acidic
or not even an insect you need the right
pH in your body or that calcium doesn't
move okay now it's true that it's the
stomach if your stomach is not acid
enough - you're not going to pull the
calcium in - that's why people with an
alkaline stomach
they have calcium issues and the way you
would know if you have an alkaline
stomach as I've talked about in the
other videos is do you have heartburn
GERD acid reflux that means you don't
have enough acid okay so guess we'll
take a wild guess what we're going to
recommend for the remedy for an
alkalosis apple cider vinegar
okay would come all come back to the
outside of vinegar take a tablespoon of
water drink that boom the twitches go
right away then you start absorbing
calcium because it's already in your
body typically you just can't assimilate
it if you don't like upside the vinegar
you can take them in tablets as well I
put a link below now why do you have an
alkaline out over the excessive alkaline
blood that's the question right what
causes alkalosis well a couple things
taking diuretics will do it number two
vomiting will do it number three
diarrhea will do it also high cortisol
from the adrenal so an overactive
adrenal which is stress will cause your
body and I'll show you in this book
this is CIPA Frank neder page 84 okay
right here the H+ you lose H+ that means
you lose acids in chemistry if you
remember taking chemistry the H+ is
basically in
so basically pH means the the power of
the hydrogen ion or basically how acids
something is so that's when you lose
this with a high level of stress okay
and then you can see your body becomes
too alkaline
so it's alkalosis right here okay so
basically stress makes you more alkaline
not more acid and this is a confusion a
lot of people have so that's why we the
outside of vinegar works so good for
stress and calcium absorption that type
of thing
now you could like I said I mentioned
the acids in the stomach too but
typically the twitching is a stress
situation and we think about when people
under stress where they start doing the
start twitching right that's because
they're dumping all this wonderful acid
and then you start getting twitch now
the question is why is it Anna left why
do you get this little left twitch right
here I don't know I have no idea
sometimes it's on the right side
sometimes it's on the arm sometimes on
your leg I have no idea but the point is
that you can use this as a little red
little red flag a little indicator light
to tell your tell your body that you
need more acid okay so subscribe to my
channel and I will see you in the next
video